Rocketman is directed by Dexter Fletcher
and stars Taron Egerton as Elton John
this film tells the story of his
formative years as a child we watch him
as a kid discovering that he's a musical
prodigy right into adulthood when he
becomes one of the most successful
musicians of all time but of course that
comes with a price
when it comes to musical biopics I have
a rough time with them because some of
them take a very traditional approach
they just want to tell a story this
happened from A to Z and we got a good
actor who's able to sing sort of like
this person and we're hoping we do it
right and that's usually how all of them
go and it can get tiring they all follow
a very similar formula most of them have
stuff with drugs and alcohol and yes
this film has that as well the highs and
lows of the musician's life when they're
mega famous a lot of times these films
can get tiresome not the case with
Rocket Man this movie was a goddamn
blast I loved it
I had a really good time with it so much
of this is because Taron Egerton what
the fuck like where did this come from
this is oscar-worthy he is really really
good in this movie I was blown away with
how good he was especially since he does
all of his own singing this guy has got
it I mean I liked him in Kingsman but
like damn he can act he is phenomenal in
this movie and I'm just really excited
about how good he is in this film I've
always liked Elton John's music but I've
never been a super fan or anything my
first introduction to his music was
actually the Lion King and then after
that I listened to more of his songs and
he's obviously a legend for a reason but
it's difficult to tell a story like his
cohesively while also having it be
entertaining without making it seem like
everything else that's on the market and
in the case of Dexter Fletcher he took
an amazing approach here because this
isn't just your by-the-numbers biopic
this isn't like hey Elton John was a kid
and he learned how to play piano and his
life wasn't great and here's him doing
his first performance and here's him
doing drugs and here's his life falling
apart what this movie does differently
than all the other ones is it takes a
fantastical
approach to having actual musical
numbers within the narrative this isn't
just a by-the-book tale of Elton John's
young life this is absolutely a musical
fantasy so at times when he's a young
kid and he's feeling down he breaks out
on the song and maybe his dad does too
and then all of a sudden there's a
choreographed dance number and so it
feels really lively and really fresh and
this also helps them tell the story of
many many years through montage form
without making it seem tired because
these characters just burst out in a
song and we're normally that kind of
bugs me I'm not a huge musical fan with
a film like this it felt welcome it was
like yes I want more of that not just
because Taran Edgerton was doing such a
good job but because the film felt
really vibrant and exciting and because
it wasn't like other musical biopics it
wasn't fucking boring there was energy
like things were constantly happening
Jamie Bell is also really good here as
Bernie Elton John's primary writer
they've worked together for a really
long time he's fantastic in the movie
the entire film is filled with really
good performances but it's the music
Taron Egerton singing the energy that he
brought to the role the passion that he
brought to this role and the fact that
it doesn't sound exactly like Elton John
like he put his own spin on it kind of
and it's not like he ruined any of the
music I'm not seeing Elton John
phonetics having a problem here I do
think it's oscar-worthy and yes the
Academy is notoriously forgetful
whenever a film comes out earlier in the
year but who knows if Bohemian Rhapsody
can win best film editing anything can
happen I also like the structure of the
film the fact that Elton John is telling
this story from rehab so we see him
entering rehab and then he sits down and
he's in this incredible outfit and he's
telling everybody this story and so it
was kind of a more clear and concise way
to approach a lot that being said yeah
despite the showy visuals and the
musical numbers and the fantastical
approach to telling this story it does
hit the beats of your normal musical
biopic and sometimes that can be like
okay yeah we've seen this before but it
was Dexter Fletcher's approach to
that made it so much better and in the
long run it's kind of difficult to
pinpoint any real flaws with the movie
beyond some pacing issues there are
scenes that drag just a little bit and
sometimes yes there's a little overly
familiar sense to the proceedings but
like I said it's enlivened by the
approach and I had a great time with
Rocket Man I'm gonna give it an a - guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I look forward to more reviews very soon
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]